est-ce que ça se peut de faire une farce
attaque est-ce que vous connaissez la
série Parks and Recreation dans
l'épisode 5 de la saison 5 Leslie et
Anne font peur à un autre personnage qui
s'appelle Jerry
[Musique]
son problème cardiaque là il a des
manifestations un peu particulières on
affine le diagnostic c'est la
contraction de Heart Attack qui veut
dire crise cardiaque et de fart qui veut
dire prout alors est-ce que c'est
possible de faire une crise de prout
quand on fait un infarctus du myocarde
c'est le vrai nom de la crise cardiaque
on a tout un tas de signes différents y
compris au niveau digestif mais rarement
des prouts un truc qui existe c'est le
syndrome de romeheld c'est quand on a
une accumulation de gaz intestinaux que
nos organes digestifs sont très gonflés
et que du coup ils appuient sur le cœur
et aussi parfois sur un air qu'on
appelle le nerf vague c'est un nerf qui
déclenche des malaises un sentiment de
d'anxiété généralisé du mal à respirer
le cœur qui va vite des palpitations etc
etc vous avez capté des films de crise
cardiaque sauf qu'en fait non pas du
tout c'est juste des prout